Das sind Füchse
auf finnischen Pelzfarmen.
Sie werden so gezüchtet, dass sie
so viel Pelz wie möglich geben.
Diese Bilder haben wir
vor zwei Jahren aufgenommen.
Wenn ich Winterjacken mit Pelz sehe,
denke ich an diese Tiere
in ihren Käfigen.
Und ich frage mich:
Hat sich seither etwas verändert?
Vor zwei Jahren
bat ich den finnischen Pelzverband,
mir einen Hof zu vermitteln,
auf dem wir filmen könnten.
Aber sie wollten nicht helfen.
So entschieden
mein Kameramann und ich,
uns auf eigene Faust
auf den Weg zu machen.
(Englisch)
Wir merkten schnell:
Willkommen sind wir nicht.
* Sie spricht finnisch. *
(Englisch)
Nach diesen Absagen
kontaktierte ich Tierschützer.
Sie nahmen uns mit,
um in der Nacht Höfe zu beobachten.
So, wie sie das immer wieder tun.
Ich erinnere mich gut an den Moment,
als ich die sog. Monsterfüchse
zum ersten Mal sah.
Ihre Käfige stehen mitten im Wald.
Überall haben sie Falten,
die Augen sind häufig entzündet.
Sie müssen so viel Pelz
wie möglich liefern,
Pelz z.B. für Kapuzenränder.
Am nächsten Tag trafen wir
Tierschützer Kristo Muurimaa
in einem Café.
Mitglieder
seiner Tierschutzorganisation
dokumentieren seit Jahren die
Zustände auf finnischen Pelzfarmen.
Mit ihren Bildern
dieser riesigen Füchse
haben sie die Öffentlichkeit
schockiert.
(Englisch)
Seit damals
hat sich vieles verändert.
Verschiedene Marken
haben keinen Pelz mehr.
Auch ganze Warenhäuser
sind pelzfrei geworden.
Z.B. Jelmoli.
Auch bei Modissa
gibt es keinen Pelz mehr.
Och Sport wird pelzfrei.
Und PKZ schreibt,
sie würden ab Frühling 2021
keinen Pelz mehr verkaufen.
Aber in den Geschäften gibt es immer
noch viele Kapuzenränder aus Pelz.
Im Gegensatz zu vor zwei Jahren
viel mehr finnischen Marderhund
und etwa gleich viel Fuchs,
aber viel weniger aus Finnland.
An verschiedenen Mänteln
finde ich das Label Saga Furs.
Das ist die finnische
Pelzhandelsorganisation.
Saga Furs wollte mir vor zwei Jahren
kein Interview geben.
Darum habe ich im Internet Bilder
gesucht und diesen Film gefunden.
Hier sieht man,
wie Saga Furs Pelz vermarktet.
Rund 2 Mio. Fuchs- und andere Pelze
waren es 2018.
Ich reise erneut nach Finnland.
Denn vor zwei Jahren hat der
finnische Pelzverband versprochen,
man würde keine Monsterfüchse
mehr züchten.
Ich will herausfinden:
Haben sie sich daran gehalten?
Und wie sieht die Haltung
von Marderhunden aus?
Auch diesmal hatte ich
zuerst offiziell angefragt.
Saga Furs und der Pelzverband
haben aber abgesagt.
Erst ab Mitte Januar
hätten die Pelzfarmer Zeit
und könnten ein Filmteam empfangen.
Im Moment sei Hochsaison.
Gerade darum
will ich im Dezember reisen:
Ich will Tiere mit erntereifen Pelzen
sehen - so nennt man das.
Von Helsinki
reise ich mit dem Zug weiter.
4 Std. Richtung Norden.
In der Stadt Vaasa wartet der Tier-
schützer Kristo Muurimaa auf mich.
(Englisch)
Ich darf Kristo
und seinen Kollegen Juho begleiten,
wie sie im Dunkeln
Fotos von Füchsen machen.
Denn auch wenn es nicht mehr
ganz so viele Pelztiere gibt
wie vor zwei Jahren,
leben in Finnland
immer noch Millionen in Käfigen.
(Juho) This seems familiar.
* Kristo spricht finnisch. *
Auf einem Waldweg
bereiten sich die Tierschützer vor.
Auch in dieser angespannten Situation
bleiben sie ruhig.
Juho geht voraus
und gibt über Funk Bescheid,
wenn er etwas Verdächtiges
sieht oder hört.
Denn die Pelzfarmer wollen nicht,
dass jemand
Aufnahmen ihrer Tiere macht.
* Gespräch auf Finnisch. *
* Unheimliche Musik *
* Er spricht finnisch. *
Wir kommen den Käfigen näher.
Es ist -12 °C kalt.
* Düstere Klänge *
Take my hand.
- Yes.
Oh! Out, out, out!
Okay, it's good.
Mit nassen Füssen gehe ich weiter.
Bevor wir die Tiere sehen,
riechen wir sie.
Es stinkt enorm.
Dann, nach 30 Min. zu Fuss,
sind wir bei den Käfigen.
I take this.
Der Tierschützer
ist immer wieder erschüttert,
wenn er diese riesigen Tiere sieht.
Sie wiegen über 20 kg.
Bei einem Polarfuchs in der Wildnis
sind es 3-5 kg.
In der Schweiz werden zwar viel
weniger finnische Fuchspelze verkauft
als noch vor zwei Jahren.
Aber ich sehe: Die Tiere
werden immer noch gleich gehalten.
Der finnische Pelzverband schreibt,
man sei dabei,
die Grösse der Füchse zu reduzieren.
Aber es brauche Zeit, um in der Zucht
Veränderungen zu erreichen.
Am nächsten Morgen
fahre ich auf eigene Faust los.
Ich will Farmen mit Marderhunden
suchen.
Das ist nicht so einfach,
denn in Finnland gibt es viel
weniger Marderhunde als Polarfüchse.
Ich bin unterwegs
zu einem grossen Betrieb.
Auf dieser Anlage
gibt es 2'000 Marderhunde.
Yes.
- Oh.
Mir ist sofort klar,
warum wir unerwünscht sind.
Es ist Erntezeit.
Vermutlich werde ich auch diesmal
keinen Farmer treffen,
der mich filmen lässt.
Darum treffe ich
noch mal die Tierschützer.
Sie zeigen mir aktuelle Filmaufnahmen
von Marderhunden.
Finnland
ist das einzige europäische Land,
in dem die Zucht von Marderhunden
erlaubt ist.
Ich will auch diese Tiere
selber sehen.
Darum gehen wir zu einer Farm,
bei der man von aussen Ställe sieht.
* Düstere Klänge *
Um Käfige von Marderhunden gibt es
noch ein Gitter, das ist Gesetz.
Es ist eine invasive Art.
Diese Tiere sollten sich nicht
unter die einheimischen mischen.
Diese Art von Tierhaltung
wäre in der Schweiz nicht erlaubt.
* Düstere Klänge *
Am Ausgangspunkt treffen wir Juho.
Er hat mit einer Wärmebildkamera
gefilmt.
Er hat die toten Tiere
auch fotografiert.
Mit diesen Bildern im Gepäck
verabschiede ich mich
von den beiden Tierschützern.
Der finnische Pelzverband schreibt,
das Tierwohl habe in der Pelzzucht
erste Priorität.
Die Farmen seiner Mitglieder würden
streng kontrolliert und zertifiziert.
Mein Eindruck ist:
Die Tiere leben in engen Käfigen,
auf Gitterböden, im Gestank.
Für ein Fell,
das häufig nur zur Dekoration dient.
In der Schweiz will ich wissen,
was Schweizer Kürschner
von Zuchtpelz halten.
Ich besuche Thomas aus der Au
in seinem Atelier.
Hier hat schon sein Vater gearbeitet.
Er ist Sprecher
des Schweizer Pelzfachverbandes
und verarbeitet am häufigsten
Schweizer Rotfuchs -
von Jägern geschossen.
Einige sagen, es gehe doch nicht,
dass man Tiere extra züchte,
nur für einen Kapuzenrand.
Wie sehen Sie dieses Thema?
Ich muss es so sagen: Ich habe
sicher nichts gegen Farmhaltung.
Auf der anderen Seite:
Wenn ich schon Schweizer Fell habe,
verkaufe ich
auch kein Polarfuchsfell.
Dann propagiere ich
das Schweizer Fell.
Wenn eine Kundin trotzdem gerne
ein Polarfuchsfell hätte,
dann nehme ich
auch ein Polarfuchsfell.
Wenn man die Kunden
aber etwas aufklärt,
leuchtet es ihnen ein und
sie ändern durchaus ihre Meinung.
Ich verkaufe bzw. verarbeite -
denn ich mache
auch für Jäger selber Sachen -
ca. 200 Rotfuchsfelle pro Jahr.
Und eins bis zwei Polarfuchsfelle.
Häufig weisen seine Felle
Löcher vom Schrot auf.
Oder sie sind kaputt,
aufgrund von Verletzungen der Tiere.
Dann muss er sie flicken.
Die Schweizer Rotfüchse,
die er verwendet,
werden getötet,
weil es zu viele gebe, sagt er.
Aber er schätzt, dass nur ein Zehntel
der Felle genutzt wird,
der Rest lande im Abfall.
Er kennt die Bilder dieser riesigen
Füchse aus finnischer Zucht.
Man bezeichnete diese riesigen Tiere
ja als Monsterfüchse.
Was halten Sie davon,
wenn Sie so etwas sehen?
Nicht viel.
Das ist nicht,
was ich suche und sinnvoll finde.
Das muss ich gleich sagen.
Aber das ist eben
die Textilindustrie,
die ein Textil will, kein Fell.
Das ist das Traurige am Ganzen.
Als Kürschner bin ich an solchen
Fellen überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Wenn ich Felle von Farmen habe -
vom Polar- oder Silberfuchs -,
dann sind das normal grosse.
Etwas anderes brauche ich nicht,
kann und will ich nicht brauchen.
Was ich hingegen
noch schlimmer finde: Synthetik.
Wenn man aus Erdöl mit viel Ener-
gieaufwand und Umweltverschmutzung
etwas herstellt, was ähnlich
aussehen soll wie das Naturprodukt,
das man auf der anderen Seite
wegwirft.
Das finde ich das Traurige
an unserer Gesellschaft.
Der Kürschner
arbeitet fast nur auf Auftrag.
... d.h., mehr oder weniger rissig.
Häufig macht er Kapuzenränder.
Das ist ein Druckluftnagler.
Heute ist es zum ersten Mal
seit Langem ein Muff.
Man legt das Muster drauf.
Dann beschwert man es mit Gewichten.
Dann zeichnet man rundherum an.
Wie sieht denn das Endprodukt aus?
- Ein bisschen wie eine Tonne.
Das ist so ein Muff
mit dieser bombierten Form.
Innen ist eine Daunentasche.
Thomas aus der Au überrascht mich.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht,
dass es in dieser Branche
kritische Stimmen
zu Tieren aus Farmhaltung gibt.
Ihr habt unsere Reportage
aus Finnland gesehen.
Jetzt seid ihr dran:
Was haltet ihr von Pelz?
Würdet ihr Pelz kaufen und anziehen
oder findet ihr, das gehe gar nicht?
Ich bin gespannt auf eure Kommentare.